you won't come with
with you
or with you
whatever
hey guys pete here today i'll be
breaking down the expanse season six
episode five why we fight is the
penultimate episode of the final season
and last week's episode was where the
end started to set in and this week's
was the one that made me believe that
they were going to make these last ones
count a lot of episode 5 is setting the
table but when you have pieces like
these in play you can't really go wrong
i'll be recapping everything that
happened including what i think are some
of the richest character exchanges of
the series and i'll discuss where things
are at going into the finale right after
this quick spoiler warning if you
haven't watched the expanse season 6
episode 5 then this video won't be for
you and with that out of the way let's
get into it
on laconia we pick up right after cara
wheeled her little brother zane's dead
body into the woods looking to see if
the strange dogs could fix him she falls
asleep briefly and when she wakes the
sounds of the search party looking for
her she realizes that his body is gone
after they pass her by she hears the
dogs in the distance and when she finds
them she sees that they did fix zan and
i would say fixing quotation marks
because he's no longer dead he is
visibly a lot creepier though with dark
black eyes and strange movements and
from what he says it sounds like he can
see things that she can't overall he
still mostly seems like her little
brother though and she's just happy he's
back she gives him a hug saying the dogs
fixed him and the camera pulls away as
the score takes an ominous turn there is
one more installment to this story so i
think it makes more sense to look into
more of what's happening here after we
see that in the finale the episode
proper opens with the launch of a
torpedo as it zooms out you see the soul
ring and the free navy century ships
being overwhelmed and destroyed in the
mcrn sneak attack admiral carino is
commanding the attack and asks for a
wide band channel to talk to medina
station before they transit the ring to
take control of the slow zone she calls
for the immediate and unconditional
surrender of the station they have it
target locked and she gives them the
chance to avoid further hostilities when
they don't get a response and she's
preparing to fire their torpedoes they
start to pick up activity on the ring
station's surface they don't have time
to fully understand what's happening one
after the other each of the ships in
their fleet are hit with railgun rounds
destroying them all rip carino on the
pela marco is watching a news feed of an
uprising against the free navy on
iepetus station he's worried that it
could so doubt and turn the tide of
support away from the free navy after
drummer's raid and statement against
them rosenfeld acknowledges that if this
trend continues they could lose but says
this is why the only thing they should
be focused on now is getting to medina
with 1300 systems and hundreds of
colonies under your thumb as much metal
as we can mine as many shipyards as we
can build anyone that wants access to
that will have to ask you drummer rated
a defenseless supply depot if she wants
to act like that makes her a hero who
cares she gets a notification about the
failed mcrn attack at the ring gate and
says this calls for a celebration on the
xenobia abasarala and her people are
being briefed about the rail guns in the
ring space they learned that the railgun
is a martian design but it's made out of
metal that they've never seen before
bobby brings up that the free navy
traded protomolecule for martian
gunships and weapons and connects the
dots that maybe this was part of that
deal it turns out that the guns are
mounted on titanium bands laid right
along the surface this is how they solve
the problem of the station being
impenetrable it makes for a perfect
placement because the station
effectively has infinite inertia it
doesn't move whenever they fire the guns
and with six of them placed around the
surface the station can rain hell on any
point inside the ring space it is the
perfect defense setup and one they
didn't anticipate because they never
realized they could use the station in
that way they discount using a fast nuke
attack to destroy medina because the
last time they detonated nukes near the
station it powered up and nearly
destroyed the entire solar system there
is a chance to intercept the pella
before they get there but the window is
closing fast plus it would require them
to abandon series and let everyone there
die and there's still a pretty fair
chance that they wouldn't be able to win
the military commanders from the un and
mars are both in favor of this plan but
abasarala is hesitant she tells them
that they'll have her decision soon and
dismisses them
bobby stays behind and avasarala
explains that she refused to go along
with the strike on medina and she
wonders if she's gone too soft was she
trying too hard to be good when she
should have been ruthless bobby starts
out trying to be diplomatic but things
escalate to where she says fine maybe
you have gone a bit soft which might not
be so bad in small doses but now is not
the time for self-pity [ __ ] it's
time to keep your eyes on the enemy and
wait for the next time they slip up
because i still think we're the good
guys and i'd rather do a little less
soul searching and a lot more fighting
back abasarallah definitely takes in
what she's saying but tells her to go do
something else and dismisses her like
the others on the rossi we get one more
character return via a cameo by elvi who
is talking to naomi about the missing
ship data this was the person that
holden mentioned that might know more
about what was going on there they
noticed that there is a mass energy
threshold that precedes or perhaps
triggers the disappearance events this
means that holden was right any time
anyone goes through a ring they're
taking a major risk she asks holden
about how he can sense them getting
angrier when he transits and asks if he
thinks that they might be trying to get
out he doesn't know but says that the
artifact on illus proves they can affect
things in our world and thinks abasarala
needs to see this data right away as
they're talking naomi sees a news feed
that shows drummer and her fleet
bringing aid from the supply depots to
series and on the timing we get one of
the unintentionally funniest scenes of
the episode drummers communicating with
siri stressing that they have food and
fuel and they're just trying to give it
to them for free the un officer she's
talking to says that they need to take
control of and search her ships for free
navy partisans before they can accept
the cargo which seems like standard
procedure but if you think about it what
would that mean for characters like
walker he starts to tell her what the
consequences would be if she decides not
to submit to the terms and we see abba
serala cut in and talk to her directly
she says they'll be allowed to dock she
brings up fred johnson and how he spoke
well of her says it's nice to finally
meet her and tries to stress their
connection with free navy being both of
their enemies drummer says that fred
spoke well of her too and that they
didn't agree on everything she says a
century of oppression made marco inaros
inevitable and if it wasn't him there
would have been another avasarala tries
to set up a face-to-face meeting but
drummer says the belters on series are
hungry and she has food she came for
them not for her later joseph learns
that the gel to regrow his arm isn't
working and that they'll have to remove
his new limb while the doctor is talking
drummer gets a call on her hand terminal
from naomi she goes to the deck to
listen to the message which is asking
for a meeting and she decides not to
respond on the way to medina philip
hears the announcement about the victory
at the ringgate and that they're going
to celebrate by passing out the rare
earther brandy they liberated from
series for the crew he goes for a shift
to find out that tadeo is in the brig
and when he goes there he learns that
it's because he tried to contact his
brother on series which could have given
away their position later it's clear
that rosenfeld's plan to raise morale is
working she has a conversation with
marco who says that the united fleet has
size but they have the numbers so no
matter what they can't engage with them
everywhere at once he believes that they
can dictate how their forces will be
spread and that means that they'll
probably be able to make it to medina
she shows him what philip did in the
mess to try to get them to reconcile and
then we see his son taking a risk
checking about tedeo's brother for him
he does find out that he's dead and goes
to deliver the news and he finds out
that today it was on the crew that
planted the bombs and rigged the docks
to explode so he holds himself
responsible he's devastated because they
were told no belters would get hurt and
he thought he was only going to be
striking a blow against the inners
on the zenobia avasarala tells monica
about the information she got from prax
and how he risked his life and family
getting it to them because he thought it
might help restore earth's ability to
grow food her initial reports suggest he
might be right we learned that people
are responding well to the lucky earther
piece even though its star is getting
some death threats avasarala gives
herself an injection of a stimulant
before seeing holden on her way out
monica asked to set up an interview with
him and he says never ever ever ever
again as he turns it down with a smile
he's there to tell abasarala what they
discovered about the ship's going
dutchman or disappearing at the ring
gates and explains about the mass energy
threshold he prompts her to call him the
most naive person she's ever met when he
says that he thinks that she should
share this information with marco and
the free navy but he counters this by
saying that the threat from whatever is
doing this isn't going to go away and
anytime anyone uses the rings it could
make things worse she shows him the
pressing issue the railguns on the ring
station and explains that they destroyed
six martian warships in seconds we can't
afford the luxury of worrying about the
future until we end this war this leads
to her asking about how well he knows
drummer and her explaining that she
wants a belter ally who is respected by
her own kind to fight on their side
against denaros she explains why she
needs this to happen and he explains why
she'd never go along with it she brings
up torturing the belter in season one
and how the belt does see her that way
because that is who she was she tells
him it's not who she is now on the
station amos is loaded in the bar after
coming back from the brothel and runs
into bobby she finds out that he's not
sure if he wants to return to the rossi
at all he says i don't know what the
[ __ ] i'm doing out here anymore and she
responds that they're fighting a war
which he questioned saying cause war is
when you try to kill the other guy when
you get the chance and he tells her the
truth about hold and disarming the nuke
that he did it because he saw naomi's
kid on the pela she takes that in and
laughs because i suppose at this point
what else could she actually do he says
that sometimes it feels like he's trying
to get us killed and then a couple of
times he saves the whole human race so i
guess it balances out when he says war
is the wrong place for good men she says
good or bad it's the same place for
everyone in the end the only thing that
matters is fighting for who is covering
your flank doesn't matter if they're
saints or [ __ ] they're your people
they watch your back and you watch
theirs or you've got nothing here he has
his epiphany deciding to go back to the
ship right after he hits the brothel
again and there we see the clip i played
at the beginning of the video play out
elsewhere on the station now that joseph
had his new limb removed he tells
drummer he's sorry the fight's not over
and he can't help her anymore as he
passes back out michio tells her that
she'll stay there with him drummer is
opposed to the idea because the inners
control the station emichio makes the
distinction that they're leaving they'll
put up with the inners on the station
because they know she'll never give up
the fight with marco now and they really
can't help her drummer says that she
never loved them because they were
fighters she loved them because they
were builders and she hoped to build
something together and she walks away
feeling the weight of the decisions
she's made on the way back to the ship
she arrives at a checkpoint and even
though she doesn't want to skip the line
she's encouraged to do so because she's
pre-cleared on the way she passes saint
drani who takes a video asking how it
feels to be the inner's favorite pet and
if that's not enough when she returns to
the tynan she finds naomi waiting for
her she does apologize for just dropping
in and says it's good to see her naomi
compliments her on her ship and says
that she wants to meet her family
drummer explains that they're all gone
now somewhat brutally she explains that
oxana and berthold left after she turned
on the free navy to save the rasanante
serge was executed and now michio and
joseph have decided to stay on siri so
they don't have to continue to pay for
the choices she's made they have an
emotional back and forth where naomi
somewhat apologizes and drummer seeing
through it asking why she really came
there at first she says i wanted to see
you and she gets the quick response you
know me well enough to know that silence
meant i didn't want to be seen she gets
to the truth saying that holden asked
her to talk to her for abasarala she
wants them to fight by her side against
marco and you see drummer's face drop as
she's listening and she turns around
saying you should leave you come to me
running errands for the inners it gets
heated as drummer asks her how she can
choose their side naomi says she chose
her own side and that gets a quick
rebuttal that avasarala and our people
are no better than marco everything else
aside drummer's choices are down to
waiting for the bounty to go high enough
that someone will kill her her family is
already gone or in her words she can put
a collar around her neck and hand the
enters the leash she feels like there's
no place in this universe for her and
neither one of them can envision a
different way to move forward naomi says
all we can do now is stand by the people
we love what else is there and this is a
little bit tone deaf and drummer says
[ __ ] you you self-righteous [ __ ] but
faced with the inevitable she starts to
cry and they hold each other
from there we see avasarala moving
through the station on foot she comes
around the corner in dramatic fashion
and comes face to face with drummer in
public out in the open where everyone
can see drummer didn't believe she would
actually follow through on leaving her
ship so on some level this has impressed
her but she makes the point that the
system is filled with the graves of
belters who trusted inners avasarala
fires back that her planet is now
covered with the bodies of people who
paid the price for that she's confident
that marco will get a lot more belters
killed before this is over and she needs
drummer to help her bring it to an end
the sooner it's done the fewer people
will die on both sides kamina asks if
she'll remember the belters who died for
her victory after marco is dead she can
only promise she will and that she's
given belters plenty of reasons to hate
her but none to think that she's a liar
even though neither of them thought they
would see the day that belters would be
fighting alongside inners against other
belters they shake hands to form a union
and the episode ends there i think what
impressed me most about this episode was
that it had to explain a lot of things
in dialogue for everything to make sense
heading into the finale but i thought
they did a masterful job in balancing
things out with such great emotional
interactions between characters at
different points in the episode they
made the choice to hold back what marco
was really up to that his master plan
shifted to him setting up shop behind
the rail guns and being in a position
where he had resources and the means to
build his own fleet to rival the others
in the system i thought the way that
they introduced the guns worked and even
though carino paid the ultimate price
it's one of those situations where the
information they gathered was vital
since that was going to happen to
someone the free navy got all of the
materials and the guns from the laconia
gate so it seems like they were able to
fortify the ring space in secret
drummer's statement to avasarala about
the inner's behavior making marco
inevitable is really important and i
think they did a fair job of presenting
where she was coming from i guess it
gets easy to overlook because the short
season requires her to rethink this core
belief in the same episode but it's key
that no one on the inner side of things
really tries to dispute her claims the
grievances she has and the belt in
general have are legitimate and that
makes things complicated even when
violent extremists follow through with
the massive terrorist attack on earth i
think it goes without saying that where
this episode really excels is in the two
characters in a room talking to each
other department and it just had so many
emotionally charged exchanges that it's
crazy that they all happened in one
episode the way that amos is working
through the balance between thinking
holden was trying to get them killed and
saving the entire human race was perfect
and the whole interaction between him
and bobby was a highlight reel it's a
fitting end to his internal conflict
about what he's doing out there because
they have been through too much to throw
it all away at this point over one
decision and as the x-ray episode points
out holden never really went looking to
be in the middle of everything in the
first place the naomi and drummer
reunion was definitely the hardest
hitting in the season and possibly the
series and there's so much history to
keep track of i think here is where the
x-ray episodes really added to the
experience you have to think back to the
end of last season and everything that
led up to drummer turning against the
free navy and what it cost her in the
end she essentially did that because of
naomi and when she's backed into a
corner here she brings that up that it's
all tied back to those feelings so when
naomi tells her that the only thing left
to do is fight for the people you love
she knows that's the truth but it's
still a bitter pill to swallow and there
is a ton more to get into and i could
talk about this forever and we'll try to
do that when we get into the live stream
in the next couple of days there were a
couple of things that sat wrong with me
as a book reader the first time i
watched this even though i love the lb
character she's one of my favorite povs
in the books i felt a little
disappointed that it felt like it was
her that figured out what was going on
at the ring gates rather than naomi and
a couple of other small things jumped
out but they didn't take away from the
overall experience of watching the
episode and on re-watch it made a lot
more sense i think that we're in a good
place to leave this one so let me know
in the comments what you thought about
the episode how you're feeling about
things going in the table is pretty set
up i feel like there's probably anxiety
going around for show only people but
they're hitting the character beats and
things are unfolding so just hang in
there please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon